bonjour et bienvenue dans le studio
diagonale tv cinquantaine 2015
championnat de france et bien je suis
avec la double tenante du titre la
championne de france et nino maso a dit
bonjour nino bonjour alors supershuttle
important jusqu'à présent oui ça va ça
va j'ai trop en fait j'ai pas les
apparemment le plus simple cette année
il faut dire parce qu'il ya beaucoup de
noir et j'ai déjà doublé les noirs aussi
et j'ai joué sur six parties 4 noir déjà
et en plus ça se continue en fait parce
que j'ai que sophie avec les blancs et
allure avec le noir le contact le noir
tout le monde incluant presque enfin les
meilleurs lots donc on verrait et par
rapport à effectivement six partis noirs
j'ai pour 25 points sans défaite
je trouve ça bien c'est vrai que c'est
pas mal et c'est assez impressionnant le
rythme pu tuer puis en plus hier tu as
tu as pu gagner une partie vraiment au
forceps parce que ça puisque 120 coût
115 10 526 coup avec une finale tour fou
contre tours est très difficile à
défendre et tu as réussi à gagner
oui enfin c'est ma faim j'ai gâché la
partie plusieurs fois parce que c'était
une partie assez compliqué où j'étais
assez mal mais bon à certains moments et
de me rattraper généraux ont travaillé
dans cette partie on peut dire et puis
bon mon deuil après a priori j'avais
encore le garant du simple kg de on a
tout raté d'un doublé avec mon métier et
puis moi je dis joue autant pour enfants
remporté cette pratique ça me faisait
vraiment présenter parce qu'enfin jamais
l'impression que cette partie m'apporte
plus de joie que double titre
j'ai l'impression que je sortais
d'allumage de photos j'ai fait un
jogging intentions pendant six heures
que c'était intervenants de cette partie
j'ai pensé la partie la plus longue déjà
que ses jeunes amis quoi en fait
aussi à gagner il ne restait que à peu
près 5 où je croise peut-être six
jusqu'à ce qu'elle ait le plus réclamé
l'annulation était près de 50 coups
voilà en tout cas une partie importante
importants comme ça on perd le demi
point ci par là et après ça soit sur mon
résultat à la fois sociaux alors et en
termes sportifs sur le championnat
c'était important parce que tu revenais
à la hauteur de almira skripchenko qui
fait aussi angoissé bon championnat et
aujourd'hui tu là même tu arrives à la
dépasser puisqu'elle n'a fait que nul et
toi tu as réussi la fois vrai dire pour
dire la vérité je regarde pas du tout
presque les points d'habitude ça ne
m'intéresse pas du tout au courant des
championnats parce que moi j'essaie de
jouer mes parts et elle ça veut rien
dire enfin déjà toujours ça dépend qui a
joué qui a joué avec elle plaît enfin
donc les points pour moi aux mille tours
9 ça va vraiment rien dire merci c'est
bien j'ai un bond de 7,0 à 5 sur 6 mais
c'est encore trop tôt pour parler c'est
un tournoi très longue il faut aussi
rappeler qu'avec ton club vit filaire tu
es aussi championne de france par
équipes oui par une double l'équipe de
rocksteady sport cet étrange tous les
titres en tant que oui effectivement oui
comme c'est d'usagé par équipes mixtes
et arrêté frémir les champions de france
c'est chaud nino maso rasé super
championne alors on va noter juste le
monde des joueuses donc tu tu avais tout
allait noir donc c'est sophie afflalo
oui française écrit comme ça sur mes pas
me tromper et hino donc ma is who
comme ça ça doit être à peu près bon
déjouer excusons si c'est un peu faux
toi tu avais les noirs oui voilà on va
regarder du côté nord cette partie donc
sophie aph la loi les blancs tu as les
noirs c'est parti avec 4 2 4 c'est
simple ces cinq élèves trois cavaliers 3
d'une sicilienne sait pertinemment et 6
et la wii alors ça c'est tout qu'est ce
que c'est que ce coup comment ça
s'appelle cette variante
ok ok dit d'accord donc là en général je
pense que parce que c'est un petit coup
de pioche de monde qui fait là bas il
faut pas sous-estimer sa course au sol
en sarre et transposent d'un testing et
du coup ça peut être embêtant pour
l'adversaire table ça dépend c'est
qu'elle joue en façade et pense qu'elle
va jouer maintenant
et là elle a joué des quatre coins c'est
simple week donc elle a juste ouvert
repoussions juste un peu ouverte à un
peu normal en disant à ses sincères
aurions probablement donc pour prise car
oui les écarts vis qu'avaient les
prendrai qu'un trait aux lib 6 et la
cavaille aussi au regard d un petit
piège au fond mon pied j'ai aussi eu ce
1er effectivement une gamme a5 et chez
quoi si on joue en scène pour attaquer
de cavalli qui semble même plus
classique dans la sicilienne je pense
que à toulouse c'était pas ça la
préparation les le public le public qui
nous suit parfois il ya des débutants
qui veut le savoir les petits pièges
aussi là et donc c'est un petit piège 5
damascène et chez soi et on va prendre
le pion à son jeu très rarement le chaos
il ya six ans ian si on le sait 5e c'est
pas forcément une bonne idée d'habitude
ouais donc là il n'ya pas 2,5 donc la
norme annoncé le coup ko la c3 qui est
le plus joué sauf qu'elle n'est joué
tous des 3 l âge ou le feront des
heureux comprendre pourquoi parquet
l'idée ou puis c'est passé et stéphane
dessus des vignes oui on veut jouer
c'est à nous de mettre le système
démarre aussi plutôt les tons nude maroc
6 et
effectivement dominé pour mieux la
position donc vous n'êtes pas en fait
moi j'ai pris beaucoup de risques dans
cette partie aurait dire qu'ils
n'étaient pas obligés à faire j'ai
supporté par et 5 très agressivement ses
traits des récifs ont en fait l'idée
c'est que si k-way par quelque part
apparaît trop ce qu'était la partie avec
trois oui des cinq avions très
rapidement c'est-à-dire non réelle de
tous les jours des céciliennes mourir
très rapidement la position
c'est ce qu'on veut vraiment il fera pas
comme les autres os appareil critique au
sens soit un q5 de cinq attaques et des
5-6 un coup très risqué que je fais
quand même tu as fait ça les fait
glisser une éruption sont très fortes
avec plein piège des pompiers journée
planquer des cinq avait beaucoup de
pièges est-ce que tu laisses occurrence
incomprise oui je l'espère qu'une autre
est presque tant l'idée évidemment on
devine que j'ai justement parmi les
seize sa marotti quoi ces quatre tu veux
pas les après 2,5
ça va pas être bientôt voir germer donc
ça va être compliqué une autre partie
éléments de la grille je trouve cette
est possible la sortie repoussée cinq
des six puisse être pourquoi pas donc
c'était pas forcé de s'affoler comme ça
mais je trouve que si j'ai galéré thèmes
ont appelé noirs ou arabes je prends
davantage de majorité de pions il faut
nous faire donc la sica où il prenait 5
l'a fait sans y a pas fait mais cette
fois raison
rd oui il ya beaucoup de jeunes beaucoup
d'hésitations les rues paris d'un coup
d'essai simpara si bien en fait il est
assez rigolo je vais vous montrer
c'est ici en france 0,4 alors si on s'en
sert également de modèles jeune et jakub
et 5 alors fou des cinq échecs toy
bizarrement puisque je me fous oui à b
et que cette dinde de 8 ko 9,7 et là il
y en a sept philippins ténor qu'avaient
les ponts avec déchets pour moi et on
prend la tourbe
mais le père ly risque d'être engagé par
exemple je pensais vous invite ici
peut-être cavalier a chuté j'étais en
train d'évaluer cette position par
exemple personnel son rock ce qui se
passe il faut pas que j'ai peur 30
millions mais je pense que les joueurs
sont comme mieux ici au maroc oui j'ai
même passion que j'ai mieux que ça donc
j'ai quand même décidé de façon de jouer
sainsois par ses citoyens mais plutôt
sur l'autre peut-être food est ici très
intéressant de sisli donnez vous des six
c'est que cavaillé ne peut pas reculer
sur f3 parce que bouaké fléchettes avec
des pros on est quant à lui sur les
claviers en lien étroit avec le pion et
deux pièces attaqué - opéré en pièces et
aux dames et dodin mais cette fois la
patronne wesh et puis si fous rires 4 4
6 et ç'a l'air louche
enfin c'est le noir dubaï à salir louche
d'accord oui mais oui c'est moi j'hésite
et vous faire danser cette fois la dame
c'est cette simple les abysses ah oui
tout est en prison à protéger toujours
grande clouage qui arrive et là des
grosses problème c'est les bleus
souffrent et maurice
bref voilà en tout cas que les scènes
pour elle aussi comme on voit c'est est
resté donc c'était assez piégeuse pour
hamilton s'il prendre sur des 5 raid et
celle ci elle avait pris sur dc n a pas
pu m'en éloigne au plus bas
les plusieurs possibilités ici aussi
mais par exemple j'hésite à l'heure du
gaz une pièce commun avec l'opérateur ni
et un et deux et ça il faut analyser
parce que ça c'était également
compliquée à tocane collèges voisins ont
joué dans cette voie là la question est
ce qu'il ya dames cette fois mais il ya
des six à la décision très attention à
cet être épais josé van dam
parce que là si on veut garder le
vis-à-vis faut venir en russie ce oui
mais je peux sortir le fouet et gagnent
autant derrière je suis mal non mais ça
marche je prends pas des masses et on
ajuste tranquillement mes propres par
exemple le client sur 2,5
on reprend avec lada et puis bah non pas
ici pas ici parce que là j'ai des
problèmes avec l'ès troyes ac avant pour
ces quatre suspects grâce à luiz pour
bien des scènes tout simplement
et ici en fait et si je peux prendre un
pur et aussi les faux que j'avais va
stabiliser la position
si j'arrive à sortir les pièces héros kg
serait mieux parce que je marchais
majorité d'opinions et je ne sais pas si
c'est la recapture contre 3 ici mais la
marque en tout cas pour les moins 25
pouces noires ce concert et combien ont
vraiment c'est plus ou moins légales
probablement où je veux dire comme gens
sont morts non plus de pouls et on sait
par contre ça dépend si j'arrive à haut
risque comme tel à partir pourquoi
d'accord donc on revient dans la partie
et la plus grosse réflexion ni si elle a
fait d'un mais de la mode est
intéressant quand il est également
possible de mettre quoi pas là le prends
pas elle prépare le couple qu'on a vu
qu'ils se jouer dans beaucoup de
variantes combien de morts dont l'âge
est principalement deux choix soit
poussée des quatre soit pressurer quatre
soient prises en quatre oui donc j'ai
tout décidé d' effectivement encore une
fois risquée ouvrir la position d'un dea
l'idée c'est d'obtenir perdre est fou
c'est la partie donc j'ai planté comme
les gars vous prenez 4 prend et les
caennais prenaient que j'aime et qui le
pousse et tu as la fameuse paire de fou
oui mais
en réalité ça paraît très risquée d'un
premier 4 pourquoi parce que je suis
vraiment pas de vous développer un
regard de nokia sur wii tiers et si
j'avais pas mais développe est
proprement et correctement ça risque
d'être complètement dégradé la pollution
comme temps clair et beaucoup beaucoup
réfléchir aujourd'hui vous pour évaluer
cette position s'était réellement
jouable ou pas voilà c'est par exemple
l'âge et me demander est ce qu'il faut
jouer c'est ce qu'a laissé six ou de 6
parce que l'autre truc c'est que tout
risque de blessure au dos il ya pas de
pression reste de la course interne à
100 que cheikh toujours oui si on bien
phu d66 lecavalier prend ya toujours ce
couple ramasse un échec et april prend
le cabinet que j'essaye de comprendre
quel lourd de coûts était le meilleur
balle pourquoi est-ce que très
rapidement j'ai remarqué que betty
rockhouse trois tours jianchao les
dessins qui arrive en fait très
rapidement et beaucoup plus rapidement
que mont roucous un truc jong
là je me perds en redire quand il sait
si ce mot quand même sortir car ici
c'est toujours pareil si elle prend
damas 5
oui échec et en perd une pièce on peut
paraître comme les c3 ils ont dû
attendre les tirs au départ et se
déplacent pose d'ongles elle menace peut
être car il est prêt et 5 entre autres
de ce qui a précédé chez m6 m6 a en fait
tard je besoin
alors au lieu de jouer aussi bien j'ai
quelques variantes intéressantes à 19,6
par exemple couper 4 alors si foulée
calvaire c'est intéressant
oui mais moi je sais pas ce que j'ai pas
aimé ici c'est petit groupe on prend pas
aux cinq petits retenue on peut pas
laisser prendre 1 et 5 parce que il y
aura des cloisons verdun mais cette en
fait il est madame et 4 mondial est pas
protégé parce que c'est
aussi c'est sans doute le clou oui parce
que la dame ne pas protéger par le
cavalier c'est pour faire quelque chose
et là par contre j'avais peur que quand
il a des seins tombants corps ou dans le
pire des cas je vous dire ça vous prend
foot français 3 donc tu prends le calme
est obligée de sa structure mais j'ai
déjà l'espère des fonds d'entreprise
maintenir fois troqué menace oui kim
lafave relais c'est drôle mais en fait
mon problème c'est que si jérôme alors
que ça devrait quand même si j'essaie de
le fou à la limite et ses hommes il ya
camille et g5 un coup très moche que
j'aime mieux mais pas pour moi à oui il
n'y a pas de gp 2 5 a concédé un point
quatre échecs donc j'ai aussi par
exemple un source
alors il faut montrer sur l'aps m dames
échec oui et si l'on revient la fuite
est actuellement à vii nos chefs et se
donner la paix oui c'est sa qualité
donc j'ai 6 et 6 g 6e le visiter à
partir sur cette fonction dans la partie
c'est moche théâtre d'un match car ils
voient que c'est pas terminé son apogée
review h5 et voilà on voit ça c'est pas
très joli et plus de peur de foudroya
s'est affaiblie comme est même si la
structure il ya qu'à cherbourg les cases
noires sont faibles il a le bon fond ça
c'est pour ça que vous devez garder
marque fred haslin participer car oui je
sais que mes nerfs c'est pour ça que je
suis obligé tôt ou tard faire f 6 pour
sinon autrement j'ai repéré tout le
temps de corriger cinq ans fait donc des
fiches tu construis ton centre oui j'ai
un peu chaque abonné g5 un moment donné
quand j'avais son drop
yvette et rock donc elle rapidement fou
et c'est alors là j'ai trouvé si le coup
j'ai pensé une seule plein possible
c'est-à-dire tour des ans et que je
m'attendais très naturel pour i alam
thatcher la dame nouvelle z ce serait
les pas le meilleur mais bon comme les
deux simples et a trouvé une sorte de
réfugiés sur cette attaque la dame mais
depuis en fait c'est mon aventure vient
recettes donc la demande d'eau
bien sûr la case of 7 pourquoi je me
suis autant de torture a aujourd'hui
j'ai réfléchi automne se rendaient
moment partout quand j'ai pris le bien
sûr et 4 ou des parcages ouvrir la
position là j'ai obtenu père de vous
j'étais en train d'évaluer ces types de
pollution en fait c'est à dire est ce
que la dame peut se cacher qu'incapables
parce qu'ils ont l'impression que la
dame c'est vrai partout mal placé il ya
les clones et 7 qui menacent fourchette
et si j'arrive pas ici a rapidement
sortir les pièces où la dame en cinq
mois j'ai mais pas trop parce que c'est
trop exposée la voix il ya plein de
menace et après par exemple je sais pas
fou des docks quelque chose il le foot à
clapet à 3 3 où je sais pas tu cherchais
des cases pour saddam en voilà et la
piété contente d'avoir trouvé obscène
c'est ça oui même si c'est encore ça
paraît un peu risqué mais s'attire la
position toujours ce qu'on dirait
organique ou presque parce que
maintenant en province et qu'elles font
me fit non plus la pause casse le truc
c'est que moi j'ai pas induit des
données nuit fond noir ni tout blanc
je trouve que si je donne un défaut
j'aurais plus du tout la chance
davantage pourquoi parce que si je dois
vous bien les cases blanches sont très
faibles avec ou structurel 6,6 g d'un
fou à gaspé 6 et 7 sont très faibles et
sans pouvoir bouger vraiment de tout
régler mais c'est vrai j'ai besoin
vraiment peur de fou j'ai besoin que je
trouve la place et je n'ai pas pour
l'atteindre
tout faux pour cacher des cavaliers pour
que ça se change pas que pour que j'aie
rock et après et si j'arrive à faire ça
après j'ai pour cette 5e c'est
stratégiquement presque gagné cette
pollution en vigueur
il retrouve s'attaquer mario sur le
blosne en tout cas donc ça c'était la
mission presque impossible que j'avais
aussi à faire c'est à dire ici donc
j'espère c'est par ces au point de jouer
elle fait ses 4 elle a fait c'est à
deauville consolider la position de son
cavalier au centre oui parce qu'il était
alors si l'étape tir par f5 comme ayant
l'air
oui tu pouvais attaquer la dalle oui oui
oui les temps étaient derrière un pouce
et 5 c'est la seule chose que j'aimerais
moi comme je voulais vraiment pas
échappé de fontbrune fouet 3 alors
maintenant tu peux plus faire pousser
ses fous des six ouais c'était ça l'idée
toute l'idée de cette partie des maîtres
des six est en fait un cas d'attaqué
nous faut par son v8 carrément la wii et
géreront quai a préféré commencer à tout
pour capter les occaz pour ta d'appétit
une pièce pour tous ces traits passé
mais moi j'étais en train de réfléchir
c'est comme une bombe en fait ça va
exploser cette poésie parce que ça soit
tôt ou tard tu pourras jouer 5 le cas
donc le fourbe et vite très vite il va
devenir très fort complètement dingue il
s'est fourré 6 et il fallait aussi
trouver la place et les jouets publicis
il fallait aussi trouver la place pour
moi tour vérifie dans sept 7 ou parfois
de ces décès ouais t'as trouvé
déclaration terminée voilà là j'en dirai
mieux si je veux qu'un jour là ses
bourreaux près 7 rebonds et j'arrive
dans un seul coup elle peut plus
empêcher donc tu vois cette place et je
suis montrée critique j'ai pensé à tous
faisant j'ai réfléchi j'ai avec moi à
peu près plus qu'une des mers presque un
jeu wiiware est positionné après j'ai
joué tout impôt tous ces coûts étaient
là tabou parce que j'y réfléchis donc
j'ai tout l'été en fête après alors
qu'est ce qu'elle a fait donc ici et là
fait une fois à 3 à 3 radio attaque à
l'ied hamsun allemand c'est pas mal
parce qu'elle a effectivement elle a
trois pions contre 2 donc laisser
quelque chose et pets et rots et ça y
est enfin du rock et après avoir bien
placé des pièces partout et là
maintenant tu vas y réfléchir très vite
très bientôt
est-ce que tu joues à 6 avant aussi
savonnage 6 pour empêcher qui avait fini
en baisse mais les impasses qui en plus
a commencé à être humain le temps aussi
bref c'est donc si ça y est tu enlève
tout casa aux cavaliers et tu veux jouer
maintenant f cell et les blancs peuvent
pas faire grand chose
oui donc pour l'empêcher pour l'empêcher
je sais ça devient dur j'ai l'impression
cette position est en fait la fille un
peu une chose bizarre cavaliers p4 est
en fait je pense qu'elles savent plus
exactement comment gérer cette can qui
arrive et c'est vrai que c'est très bien
fait c'est hype et 4 alors sacrifier un
pion mais c'est pas très bon mais je
pense qu'elle a fait peut-être parce
qu'elle croyait péter attard je ne sais
pas je peux demander qu'à y avait quatre
à prendre des guêtres et sur fonds
propre et 4 c 5 6 1 6 4
ah oui un coup comme c'est simple c'est
ce que j'appelle nos poumons et à 5 10 à
5 et il ya 5
oui en fait vous pourrez vous venez
juste un petit mot une telle entrée ne
trouva rien de plus intéressant qu ici
en fait après quand il paie 4 j'ai
également dû calculer quand il promet 4
pendant à glamour aussi au jour par will
to buy également du calcul et d'une
attente autour de sites et ça perd
également sa vie en achetant du grand
déçu oui salaire est la folie mais il
fallait vérifier quand même pourquoi oui
pourquoi aucun gaz
quelle est la différence voire et là où
c'est 5 ha oui est-ce qu'il ya touquet
en prix minimes g chaos les détroits
justement ici malheureusement pourrait
alors moi j'ai calculé fou prendre des
six ça c'est très intéressant comme à
rien et peut pas jouer le jeu en 3d
mieux parce que fo sa cinquième présence
sur le foot en prison
marion tous et je ne sais pas
j'ai quand même fou de six mois jusqu'à
20 ko les siens j'ai quelques jusqu'au
final ça vous savez fuite en disant
qu'elle peut être renvoyée ne sort pas à
peut-être tu vois a pour tous les prix
c'est à vous de calculer combien j'ai
calculé 97 doper des trains métros avait
tenté de séparer voudrez de 17,1 des
justes et quatre en fait eux quatre ils
valent en a mis ses six corps et leur
qualité 3,6 si la dame prend et dans
lequel est de sortir et si le cas vrai
joue par exemple en déclin carrière bien
désolant et c'est terminé on s'en sort
et on n'est pas obligé d'aller où serait
pas mal j'ai pu me dire qu'est ce que
l'art est douce mais quelques apparel a
dû croire du tout à ça marche mais ça
accélérait la partie sinon c'était quand
même dur je trouve que la position
je ne sais pas comment un ordinateur
exactement destine à ponctionner encore
les p4 mais je veux dire humainement
c'est très dur cette position déjà je
trouve que les noirs sont au mieux sans
cavalier peut être aussi parce que c'est
un quatre dames 5 fu h torreilles je
sais ça horrible quoi bien voulu comment
donc tu fais le meilleur à paris j'ai
fait le meilleur jeu peu compliqué j'ai
qu'elles veulent c'est bien parce que ça
affaiblit après cinq jeux plus besoin de
prise simplement tu prends et t'as pas
peur ccsl à fait mais à 5 parce que la
dame s'y attaqueront est pas mal mais en
fait tout simplement asem et finira ce
fouilles j'étais en train de me dire je
l' ai vu cette position comme le village
où dit il presque muet en b 4e des 6
passes quand des six bons ils tueraient
lampions et là maintenant ben oui
contrôle des causes des quinze ans
un peu des échanges de placement de
bizarre mais aussi s'enfermer chez moi
d'être enfermée chez elle mais mon
femmes ayant bien sûr le fou a l'air pas
mal
et donc là c'est quasiment toujours
pressés ou quasiment terminée la bourse
et donc encore des coups donc qu'est ce
qu'elle a vu israël a joué 6 15 h quatre
cavaliers est en tête de tenter de jouer
les quatre déchetteries cela valait 35
oui mais on est mal orienté souci oui je
dois faire un potentiel comme de bons
fous des dom alors fou doit beaucoup de
motifs tactique il faut qu'elle décide
ensuite notre silhouette retour 7 euros
ou si elle va jouer tour en course et de
fougue et 3 elles recevront le compliqué
c'est de saison avant qu'ils étaient
tous les trois des morts je passe des
fans parce qu'il ya et le pro tour ou au
départ je me trompe et maturité des de
la salle et on apprend ici je suis chez
moi à perdre une finale très rentable
reprises aux prises il n'y a plus rien
wen est mort à quatre reprises et c'est
la dernière en date fait tout qu'elle
connaît tout le temps c'était quand même
assez tactique cette porte s'étonne pas
de four b3
donc on est très soudés deux pas se
retrouve ces deux pas de son pétrole
mais pas pour les autres cons qui
gagnent c'est ça l'idée tu vois tourner
un il ya les mortiers de maths
là évidemment encadré
fougeux 5 j'ai déjà pas mal aussi oui
voilà ici autour des 4 c'était pas moi
je suis directement mais savent par
exemple l histoire c'est que ce retour
dix ans je prends un tome de cette série
menace le mat sur ds est compliquée en
tout cas d'otages esprits avec un team
inscrire mon fils est rêveur
vice-championne plus un poster de fonds
plus les maths choisi
et puis tu monte à 7,5 oui parce que dès
que la dame sort de la défense du
cavalier il est perdu et si elle vient
ici à 4 regarder la bactérie dame fou
peut venir en b3 ouais c'est l'âme bref
les parties surtout ron elle a peu joué
comme ça il a compris que c'est d'être
d'un giro à l'avant alors fou d2 alors
sur faut des deux taux à 1 elle a joué
en grèce qu'elle a vu pour le nom de
merde voilà elle a vu ses fautes et la
foulée 3 mai cette preview si vous
perdez foussat collabore très bien et
voilà sa léthargie politique ouverte
c'est vrai oui parce que tout bien fait
avec notre belle la tournée on oui parce
que l'on se demande ce qu'elle fait là
en commun à part dont hélas pas fait
tourner fait d'abord ses six autrement
il perd par doutons d-4d jacques adamo
et le pev karine h4 en fait ah oui
brian menace tunnel des quatre bras
bouger et le kayak a choisi l'entreprise
a donc
elle doit donner encore un pion elle le
fait c'est celle ci devrait ouvrir sans
fous pour protéger des 4 comprend des
cas d'accord n'est pas c'est pas il n'y
a pas de manipuler c'est surtout pour
contrôler cette case d'abord france et
donc des processus et des années les
bars et dans la qualité d'image et tours
sont horribles greystone rouge il n'y a
pas tant des quatre led jeu food qui
domine la position d'accord alors à
priori c'est aujourd'hui que débute
intéressant jeunesse le plus affecté 8
tomber 8 timité c'est que sont attaqués
des j'arrête le foot n'est pas déjà pas
mal hein pas trop de casse mais un cas
de fouille être promu ya carrément tour
b4 aussi il ya le truc est d'axer sur
catherine cette fois c'est la théorie
bien sûr si le fougueux 3 pb cap protégé
par un sac
donc ça tombe très mal à se résoudre à
temps partiel chez vous prend à celles
des voisins commencent à proposer parce
que vous prenez celle qui te prendra
cinq tours des cas les autorités locales
le cavalier aussi james ait note c'est
pas facile mais le plénum c6 très
naturel oui ça pour ça qu'on s'intéresse
peu de temps mais sur un trottoir
seulement perdre mes préférés sur 100 tu
prends un peu douée elle a pris la 3 e
et protège très bien et d'un dessin que
j'ai joué à priori femmes des actus
centralise une histoire c'est que
j'échange les daims et après comme le
fond reste toujours attaquer bannières
et le prix d'un point dé 53 des gens
autour qui protégea simple si importants
et d'une fille n'y avait plus assez les
pions à 5
oui complètement protégé foutraque et
une fois quasiment pas de place et si
elle partait pas reçus pour un fou et 3
je fais est fou c'est d'ottawa faut 3
pouces et 2 et autour d'applications la
casse aurait femmes nées après il perd
encore un pion sur mes deux jambes rb2
et après tu vois c'est on a beaucoup de
pions des pelouses et lui à pied qui
passe je change le foot j'ai gagné la
finale de pure et plus on est tombé il a
fait un coup intermédiaire cavaliers f5
intéressant les intéressent en ces
périodes normales moussaoui s'attaque
cette
dans cet échec où est la tour et périls
et celle ci une tentative j'en étais en
huit tentatives tout à fond et donc ici
g le chou à tout âge ou leur entrée avec
30 sur décisive entre dans cette filière
doute de fous complètement gagnantes
soient bon joueurs loin quelques
apparaît encore oui mais c'est pas la
peine du prix tout simplement tu as pris
6 en quatre sets rouge les séries
puisque sur cavaliers pros mission
francs du jour et tu as deux fous pour
nous surtout il faut remercier qu'il n'y
a pas de tour des impasses que j'ai tout
retombe et deux tours démarche pas parce
que c'est ça l'important c'est celui en
ramasse on récupère le fou mais non ils
sont bien tombés de la presse est juste
trop de primes de plus elle fait tour à
3 là encore fait tour à 3 ce que nous
mais je m'attendais tour 4 qui était un
peu mieux mais tout est contre il a déjà
perdu notre pions nous et c'est là un
faux et 4 les fondations d'éteindre ses
pions voilà on est obligé de bouger et
regarder de quoi et l'abandon de la
caisse qu'elle a joué encore peur autour
des 1
v2 en b2 moi je pense qu'on peut
s'arrêter ici un très bon spectacle vers
un voilà au même je pense la fin donc la
tâche noire et écrasant pseudo fou c'est
beaucoup plus sûr qui tourbillonne
imaginé il ya passionnés après ce détour
dominé c'est pas mal et se sont même pas
des tours actif donc ces puits selon
vois pas comment les blancs peuvent
aucunement ils peuvent pas empêcher ceux
pions d'avancé puisque les fouilles vont
voir celer les tours et il va passer la
main serrant ses katas prince il faudra
encore donné une tour contre le pion et
oui et c'est là que je sers chinois par
rapport à une longueur tout ça on a
l'impression que c'était une partie
quand même simple facile mais après
c'est à lui que les nouveaux stades en
fait tout s'est joué au début j'ai eu au
début je vais quand même pas me torturer
un métier c'était pour moi une partie
simple mais avant le tournant surtout
c'est une partie importante
oui le ça te permet maintenant de d'être
leader du tournoi qui était à tuer
maintenant un demi point devant le
miroir certes elle est intéressante de
google est vraiment commencé le deuxième
phase de tournoi c'est après le jour de
repos justement où j'ai donc sophie et
almira les douze matches auxquels tout
de suite d'accord
par contre tu expliques ça que tu tues
réussit très bien ce championnat de
france surmotivés quant aux chances de
ses protégés
non mais c'est tout expliqué stefan
gimpl trombe et peut-être que je dois
arrêter effectivement dû au temps d'un
retour du monde et pour tenter de donner
un exemple rien que par exemple dans
décembre décembre dernier j'ai joué
trois tournois filer en angleterre et
j'ai fait vingt sept parties sur 32 30
jours je pense oui
descoings oui ça m'arrive pas comme ça
d'ailleurs moi donc ça bizarre mais
j'ose dire j'ai fait des choses comme ça
bizarre après les gens se tournent ou
disparaissent mon classement et prendre
des risques est une joueuse est
effectivement né prend aucun soin de son
classement parce que j'aime jouer au
fait de jouer je veux dire j'ai pas un
n'est juste à venir tusk lors de mon
classement
oui d'abord s'invite à dire je vais très
bien que j'ai souvent dit je peux très
bien rester chez moi et quand j'ai subi
ou 305 40 pour quelques mois j'ai
beaucoup lu par exemple oui ça sera
jouée lynch et ouais je serai en équipe
vous êtes jeune femme et après toujours
de solex âgées aux impôts donc
s'annoncer très alors voilà c'est très
intéressant qui nous parle de ça qui
nous parle de la sélection ça serait
bien pour la sélection effectivement
mais je te comprends tout à fait comme
tu joues plus mais tu prend peut-être
plus de risques donc tout placement subi
un peu plus de variations et enfin qu'on
m'aime beaucoup
alors donc négatives et positives non
alors je crois que tu as vu à l'émission
on a des bonnes alter-eu on a invité
mathieu cornette tué sa belle victoire
et la finition très magnifique partie
hier on l'a vu et on a parlé un peu dans
la sélection alors il a donné son avis
enfin son opinion de sélectionneurs vont
apprécier le sélectionneur c'est lui qui
choisit bien entendu il expliqué voilà
et alors tu as écouté je crois un sans
abri comme simazine alors forcément j'ai
envie de te demander qu'est ce que va
passer double championne de france et on
voit que ce championnat cul ce tu peux
jouer à fond t'es sûr motivé
bon là on sait pas bien sûr encore le
résultat qui va faire puisque rien n'est
fait il reste encore une moitié de
tournant mais tu viens cette année donc
on peut supposer que tu feras sera au
moins dans les trois premières bombes et
peut-être pourquoi pas faire un
troisième titre ça serait assez beau
j'avais ça y est voilà mes donc comment
tu
comment tu vois cette non sélection en
équipe de france pour l'instant qui
t'échappe peut baser son choix je veux
dire j'étais un peu plus cette année on
va dire actifs sans que je sais pas
évidemment pas d'accord bon déjà c'est
la vie personnelle
on va dire de groupe des gens qui
considèrent que le champion national
doit être toujours un équipe nationale
pas qu'en france je veux dire mais la
plupart des pays du monde sont basés sur
ce système
par exemple l'arménie géorgie la russie
de championne est automatiquement d'un
équipement fait qualifier c'est une
évidence en fait bon en france on a
notre système est certain on est parfois
je ne partage pas cet avis considère que
par exemple si l'on pour comme un
exemple si une fillette en 1915
champions est ce que doit être par
exemple directement qualifié ou pas à
100% moi je trouve que si on double
champion du monde 1986 je sélectionnais
ressenti ça veut dire que cette personne
quand même de plus champion sans
potentiel quoi elle arrive à gérer ces
mêmes réfère ce n'est pas une
coïncidence on voit pas ce qu'on va se
poser qui nous font huer par hasard
faire quelque chose mais après mon enfin
ils disent que c'est pas écrit c'est pas
écrit c'est que la vérité c'est pas
gebelin pas là dessus
par contre c'est tout même pas
comment dire claire comme question parce
que en droit d'habitude le droit de se
constituer que des règles écrit c'est
également la coutume usages et moi je ne
me rappelle pas d'aucun cas en france où
double championne ne soit pas indiquée
par exemple pour commencer vous après
bas et on parle de mon classement sont
justement qu obama joue assez pour eux
comme c'est le cas sur maïga et le
classement elo et qui se marient
beaucoup le pont ne comprends pas c'est
souvent une prise en considération
enseignement par exemple c'est à dire si
en avril je t'ai pas en forme ça veut
dire que je vous montre classement alors
qu'elle peut être que le mois dans 40
points de plus que la personne
sélectionnée
donc ça c'est très important dans la
plupart des pays un vrai système où par
exemple en géorgie il prend le
classement moyenne sur une année
carrément la semaine maintenant soutien
au meilleur sur une année tu vois c'est
ça le classement
voyez le pays qui au milieu avec six
mois - classement de moi il n'ya que la
france qui pratiquent trois mois le
classement moyen des sélections pas pour
l'équipe parce qu'il pratique rien du
tout mais pour cas par exemple
sélectionne pour champion de france l'a
par exemple les jeunes filles qui jouent
ici
les garçons sont basés sur dernière
classement de moyens des trois mois en
gros la france et mis un pop com et de
gdf gravir trois oui en fait tout c'est
pas clair c'est que par exemple lors de
ma première sélection c'est à dire une
dernière ça cette deuxième nos sections
et l'un en fait les gens croyaient que
moi j'ai trop baisser le classement ce
qui était effectivement dans un même
temps la vérité aussi j'ai effectivement
j'avais si le classement
oui si on prend par après n'est par
exemple justement le classement moyen de
3 mois ce qui est pratiqué en france
j'étais démontrent par exemple
donc c'est à dire j'étais pas selon les
gens croient disqualifié par rapport au
classement pas du tout est déjà sans
parler de ça que j'ai passés devant avec
classement des trois mois quatre ou cinq
six mois ou années à part à tous les
classes moyennes à ses sens à part le
classement la dernière deux mots qui
l'on considère seulement
on peut considérer pascal mathieu c'est
quelqu'un des liens jacinta dit il a
toute la liberté par la fédération c'est
le système qui lui donne beaucoup de
flexibilité ce après avoir évidemment de
l'avantagé aussi pourquoi pas enfin
c'est un choix quoi j'ai comprendre à
ses sens et puis il choisit pas non plus
par le classement c'est à dire au
feeling d'habitude au chili maintenant
c'est quoi le problème moi je trouve à
ras bord les attraper sa sélection de
films x et que souvent dû prendre la
constatation forme du moment c'est ce
qui était déclaré lors de nos premières
non sélection donc moins très souvent en
france sélection c'est parce qu'ils
compris pour le championnat de france à
la vous trois mois plus tôt c'est à dire
qu'elle est bien d'en apprendre a
déclaré aux jeunes qui jouent qui joue
pas et en fait moi je trouve pas que par
exemple en avril au feeling qu'on peut
savoir qui sera rayon enfant mammouth
ottawa c'est bon et juste et m'ont fait
lors de mon premier en sélection juste
après un mois et j'ai fait performance à
2502 top 2 milliards de tonnes 12 avec
métro de mese nord de m et pourquoi donc
c'est très difficile à ses sens après je
sais pas si je pense que tu ça stéphane
il ya des situations et qu'à part où
tout le monde a raison de voir tout le
monde a tort mais c'est pas forcément
que moi j'ai raison native auteurs ou
enfin où mathilde à tort ou feinte qui a
été sélectionné à l'époque c'est pas ça
je pense que quelque part on a tous
raison à quel sens par exemple
matthew il a dû voir la situation telle
manière qu'elle m'a pas sélectionné la
première fois donc j'ai un enfant il a
eu que la saison jay perdre et si par là
les points sur les open alors que j'ai
fait c'est vraiment loupé un mondial à
mouscou 2006 elle est vraiment ils ont
fait très très dure en réalité
et puis il s'est trompé au sens sur muna
il a dû penser que c'était un peu la fin
de ma carrière en fait il a cru que moi
j'ai eu mon bébé là je commence à bosser
le classement par tous et effectivement
je trouve que c'est vrai que pour le
sélectionneur fait d'être colombie
simple à se tromper à se sentir point
est ce que cette joueuse revenu
réellement nous est-ce qu'on va juste
mais dans des centres à 2050 rester
là-bas à quoi tu vois comme ça en fait à
la base elle a choisi à l'époque donc
mathilde qui au contraire montes tu vois
qui était une joueuse en progression et
d'ailleurs les trois types de combinés
ont conduit donc et il a complètement
assuré sa sélection des relais très bien
joué et même là il continue à progresser
donc je pense qu'elle va forcément d'un
continuer à progresser je suis contente
pour elle je voulais vraiment déclare
elle-même publiquement et j'ai jamais
jamais sûrs quoi que ce soit contre
mathilde qui aimerait tenir ça aussi et
c'est dommage qu'ils aient retrouvé dans
une situation un peu embrouillé avec sa
sélection et tout ça est donc
comment dire en fête et l'a sélectionné
après mons à apprendre que le premier x
30 pour les musiques pourquoi parce que
il ya beaucoup de gens qui n'ont pas
compris pourquoi sélection enfin
pourquoi nos championnes n'est pas
sélectionné tout de même malgré enfin
mon classement ne descend pas non plus
amusant c'est à dire mon classement ces
voiries
si je fais un très très mauvaise forme
au maximum jusqu'à 2250 et au milliard
dont 350 et c'est rare que je descende à
2250 d'habitude je descende à 2280 on
est en train de 350 donc c'est pas
catastrophique choisir quand tu es
champion double champion de france pour
se faire sélectionner au classement en
sachant que les autres ne souffre pas du
tout le monde joueurs derrière souvent
des sondés pensent de moi au classement
c'est à se jouer à plein de points après
six mois on a le trio la locomotive
d'habitude qui est marie almira sophie
est évidemment qu'elles sont une équipe
je pense qu'il y aura aucun souci si je
ne sais pas matière aurait lieu lors
deux premières sélections des dix on a
tu serais au quintuple champion de
france mais on sélectionne sophie à ta
place parce que c'est moi et là c'est
compréhensible parce que sophie comme il
est toujours été de 1400 simplement même
s'il n'est pas actuellement mais ça veut
rien dire et la ligne ou des 2400 c'est
une chose est ce qu on s aime beaucoup
et là tu vois tu comprends que cette
boule pour l'équipe effectivement mais
après tout
jouer trop sévère et surtout au matinal
époque encore monter cette année série
affirmait aussi ce bon résultat pour
elle les gens me disent qu'à la double
titre
j'ai bien démontré que wall ag devriez
bien longtemps que je trouve comme mais
mathilde avec son placement de 1300m
tout le monde qu'elle avait aussi sa
place en fait c'est pas moi j'apprécie
toujours estimer combien de passer 5,85
à 38 60
oui voilà donc j'ai rampé pas en
remplaçant et bien que bref
du coup la dernière pourquoi cette année
un pot offert il voulait pas reprendre
est apparu hier à l'histoire mathiot
impôts sur il voulait pas que ce soit à
tensions entre joueurs
alors là ça va faire pour rigoler parce
que je suis une des rares personnes qui
s'entendent bien avec marie je suis très
ami avec caméra j'ai rien contre compte
sauf si on est plutôt amis et je sais
pas si lui à elle est très ouvert très
communes 4c williams et avec tout le
monde évidemment on s'entend très bien
pour nous je sais pas si elle joue non
j'ai eu aucune dispute jamais avec un
valet de ma vie avec aucune membres
d'equipe donc il veut dire par là en
fait que c'est pas que vous ne voulez
pas qu'on attention avec lui ça c'est
une évidence parce qu'elle n'a pas j'ai
aucune tension avec les joueuses en plus
très amicale avec tout le monde donc
mais c'est vrai que la tension n'a été
écrit en fait
c'est tout a commencé l'an dernier ou au
moment n'a pas sélectionné sur le coup
enfin je suis championne j'espère être
déçu c'est normal c'est qu'il ne
comprend pas j'ai quand même
effectivement ma période de crise où
j'étais à la fois l'école en colère
aussi triste aussi
et au moins 2000 et juste lui statut sur
facebook où je disais qu effectivement
je suis pas sélectionné et que mathieu
m'a dit que j'aimais pas vous mettrez
matière mais peu importe a pas légion
pour deviner et les autres jouets robots
et là il a trouvé ça très skanda nous on
veut pourquoi mettre ses statuts je
pense que très honnêtement en tant que
champions j'avais trop au monde est
triste quoi je mets pas trop de pression
veut dire et partager un truc un statut
avec les amis facebook je trouve ça
quand même
en france on n'est pas comme ça que je
suis chargé au delà de ces grandes
arnaques aussi où les réseaux sociaux
prennent de l'ampleur et symbolique
leurs quelque chose sur le jeu n'est pas
très face à fait raisonnable ce soit de
quoi que ce soit jetteront pas que
c'était résume-t-on en fait où la tête
je me trompe mais j'ai trouvé pas
c'était un certain c'était pour moi
juste les faits tout comme je crois que
juste le public lui se demandait
pourquoi le champion de france c'était
sa justesse et sa région du sénégal être
et tout le monde écrit mais pourquoi tu
joues pas pourquoi tu a décliné la
sélection résisté par rapport à ça aussi
que j'aime et qu'elle ne s'est pas moqué
des kleenex et n'était pas sélectionné
je ne comprenais pas alors au nom au 3
juin la caisse qu'on peut te souhaiter
maintenant pour pour la suite comment tu
vois les images de repos là comment tu
va accorder la deuxième moitié ça va
être tendu
tu tu as une partie importante face à
amiens tout doit aussi jouer sophie je
crois oui
moi c'est ça deux fois contre contre
sofia mire un oui un fan norvégienne
avec les services et de sel blanc que
j'ai donc ça c'est bien mais encore il
ya pris part qu'on va lire avec les
noirs ça c'est bientôt puisque c'est un
dos rond oui match important est
peut-être si je peux rajouter encore une
chose si tu veux si tu veux si tu es le
charles de gaulle s'est pas posé de
questions tellement dans deux maisons de
dramatique elle alors qu'il n'y a pas de
raison de tous même par rapport à ses
statuts faut comme il ya eu beaucoup des
changes
malheureusement ça a pris à une autre où
notre travail trajectoire on va dire que
c'est le bout était ou lebouath italien
s'était ajouté que la riche des tris
n'est pas être en équipe ça c'est vrai
et puis en fait le jeune ont commencé
impôts les fans mathilde avec mes fans
on peut dire qu'elle est mais hier -
changer enfin six mois sa partie à ces
centres et en plus mathieu qui
m'écrivait les messages privés donc j'y
arrive pas tous pour des pubs les hôtels
stades sur tout ça et ces moments là
j'avais donc la chuck bass qui me
contacter pour me dire qu'elle est enfin
diana kate ailleurs j'ai beaucoup
apprécié son soutien à mon sens c'est
pas une âme prochains mois quoi que ce
soit je l'a vu qu'une seule fois c'est
sûr journalistes on a joué juste le même
tournoi une fois un tunisie c'est tout
il me dit qu'elle était ravie qu'elle
champions doit travailler en équipe
donc elle voulait faire réellement un
article là dessus bon au départ j'ai
refusé en fait pourquoi parce que c'est
vrai qu'à olympiades étaient dans deux
semaines je me suis dit ça peut faire
aussi bizarre effectivement la dalle et
qui pour un enfant j'ai pas besoin de ça
c'est pas enfin c'était pas pour les
mettre en pression ou quoi que ce soit
en fait donc j'ai dit non j'ai pas
besoin d'articles merci de l'attention
tout ça mais après ce qui s'est passé
ils ont tellement d'insultés sur mon mur
de facebook en disant que mon titre
était presque par hasard que j'ai gagnés
sur départageant que ça rien venir
satisfaction ça va tellement ramené à
nabeul manqué avec les messages mathieu
aussi qui nous accueille au stade sujet
patron a priori des maîtres en france
est finalement ben j'ai dit oui d'accord
je vais faire de l'article je vais vous
donne interview si vous
mais l'article chez un artiste chez base
juste avant les olympiades
pourquoi est-ce que c'est pas un coup
fourré des allemands pour déstabiliser
l'équipe de finir tu penses que l'inter
doit quand même avoir des origines
allemand l'avait jamais empêché de
courir mais martigues à la base ne sait
pas grand chose c'était géant plus je
les ai souligné que si elle voulait
tellement faire partie que ce soit
réellement basé sur la question si
d'habitude dans les autres pays comment
ça se passe sur le système mais pas sur
toutes les joueuses quoi que ce soit
c'est à dire sur le système si le
champion national à sa place en équipe
nationale ou pas automatiquement par
exemple discuter de ça et c'est vrai que
ça nous a apporté certains témoignages
assez intéressante des états unis et
israël je sais pas quoi tout le monde a
commenté saucisson c'était bien c'était
juste ça le bout s'était pas de et donc
jusqu'à la main sur deux citations donc
j'ai dit que oui j'ai trouvé ça en pompe
est qu'elle ménage a surclassé 2340 et
j'étais chez moi regarder les parties de
l'équipe de france alors que j'étais
champion de l'anti très bonnes choses
des classements c'est vrai j'ai pas il
trouvait que cette fois-ci drama section
comeau je ne sais pas pourquoi ça devenu
une telle drogue et après enfin à
matthew garrett à me dire bonjour donc
toujours pas de bonjour il faut dire que
moi j'essaie plutôt amicale
un mur tout le monde et j'avais juste
que je pense mathilde a quand même
souffert cette histoire donc là dessus
j'ai vraiment de regret parce que j'ai
pas ce qu'est devenu part j'ai souffert
parce que voilà j'étais champion qui
n'était pas sélectionné d'autre part
l'agencé pas mathiot peut-être il a fait
son truc en pensant qu'ils aiment moi-je
ma carrière déterminée et bon voilà mais
c' est pas trompé sur ma tin parce que l
avènement du potentiel elle a su assurer
un mais je trompe sûrement potentiel en
fait par contre il pense pas que j'aurai
un vrai motif reste et resta est parfois
un traumatisme je pense que c'est une
chose en plus que j'apprécie beaucoup et
j'ai vraiment hâte de passer ses
messages à ses sens peut être à leur
écoute et on y mentionne aussi je
tiendrai ça parce que ça suffit que j'ai
beaucoup de sim pour te décrypte jean
baptiste personnes mathilde est par
exemple de se défoncer une fois j'ai par
exemple un open rapide championnat de la
partie rapide france et mathilde est en
train de gagner le tournoi un truc comme
ça
et à un moment donné et l'adversaire est
en train de tomber avec la passionnée
nous les lui proposons par exemple il
fait nuit tu vois il a personne qui fait
ça c'était des choses assez de boulot je
vous dirai en face à son adversaire est
en train de perdre
parce que je me rappelle tellement
impressionné je veux dire c'est une
personne honnête on a vu tout ça et je
pense que ce qui s'est passé pour elle
c'est que hélas était sélectionné pour
la première fois ça doit être encore
joué quand même et tout d'un coup ils se
retrouvent effectivement l'article
politiques ivoiriens au calme et
internationales en plus tout ça pour
elle aussi est car je suis maintenant il
ya six mois ça doit pas être très facile
après c'est pour ça je disais si vous
voyez des moments matière par des poses
championnat de france c'est à dire oui
et la part du barça tu penses non non
j'ai pensé plus ce n'est qu'elle voulait
annuler les compétitions féminines je
pense ça doit être ça si vous me trompe
pas enfin je me trompe mais tu faisais
un peu la situation c'est pour ça je
disais que tout le monde a raison
quelque part je veux dire savons pas
blâmer quelqu'un à raymond temps comme
ça quelqu'un tout le monde a fait des
avances ont besoin mais les campeurs de
victimes et on arrive à cette situation
mais je voulais quand même un problème
technique n'était pas du tout mon
attention effectivement des surtout pas
nous et aux filles jamais été mon
intention d'aider ma vie parce que je
suis vraiment d'amis qu'elle avait un
mur tout le monde et après ça on
étrangers avec lesquels ils n'ont pas
compris ce choix c'est vrai que c'était
pas uniquement par rapport à
sélectionner pas sélectionné par exemple
champions de france s'étaient parés pour
le fait que à l'époque lors deux
premières sélections par exemple
mathilde quelques mois d'avril avec 100
points que moi c'est à dire j'ai dépassé
200 points carrément après la remontée
au classement et et puis elle et elle
montre selman à l'époque mais pas grande
m elle s'en prend aux navires des mois
un moment j'ai gagné au japon en trois
jours je n'aurais pas imaginé que la
personne que j'ai lu ming tête et
partage qui a 100 points de moins que
moi c'est retrouver après l'équipe des
panneaux à quoi l'action
donc ça sur le coup ça me fait bizarre
après et la montrer qu'elle a réellement
la potentielle à elle a aussi démontré
et pourquoi pas et je pense qu'elle
verrait mais on continue à monter aussi
et je le souhaitais juste nous faut
comprendre une chose en france c'est
qu'elle noir féminin a beaucoup monté et
on arrive à un moment qu'on vous dise
pas tout de suite mais quelques années à
2952 tranquillement et l'équipe
donc là il est vrai forcément mon ado
2300 qui vont rester à une équipe c'est
justement et j'ai parce que ces conflits
finalement pas si compliqué moi je je
suis toujours très amical j'ai tenté de
dire bonjour c'est le sais je sais pas
monsieur qui n'a pas de plan pour bon
jour mais parfois ou parfois nous fait
je sais pas il comprit matinée ils ont
pouffé la tête très dommage mais je
pense que c'est surtout que sept combats
négatif finalement ça nous a fait
positive aussi au sein selon moi je me
suis remotivé j'ai peut-être parce que
justement ça va quand même vers rémy
haut niveau mathilde je pense pareil il
pousse même fait de devoir vous acharnez
elle assurait aussi sur le pjd et
jetteront que ça nous a quand même
apporté quelque chose de positif aussi
quoi et je suis prête vraiment terminer
cette histoire parce que j'ai on va pas
rester un conflit pour une chose à
moulins ou pas très grave rebond s'était
pas très comme moi je suis prêté aux
affaires première pas dire c'est pas
grave mon jeu c'est pas une équipe de
france pas tant pis il a dit hier que je
suis septième c'est pourquoi je suis pas
en prendre un équipe de france partout
la semaine et loup mais cet hymne par
rapport auquel modolo basé sûr moyen de
jours par exemple où ce jeu sur ce mois
ont tu vois et par exemple là
sixième joueur qui m'a dépossédé 9
points mais il ya deux mois j'ai dépassé
des 40 pour donc ça veut dire quoi
finalement ça veut rien dire surtout
pour quelqu'un comme moi et vous voir
comme sophie aussi des neurones en
détournant partout dans le monde
j'ai carrément l'arrêter regarder mon
classement tu vois ce que si jamais posé
là dessus vous préféré sacrifier mon
coin aller partout comme ça courage mon
venir échapper le trans aussi donc on
verra on verra mais en tout cas
bref souhaitait bonne chance à l'équipe
de france a il n'y a pas de souci avec
les filles je suis très ami donc
peut-être les admirals j'espère pour lui
qu'il va passer la crise et au sein de
pauvreté aux notables a pas de pas de
polémique - moi je suis à la base une
personne très pacifique donc moi ça mais
tant que gérant tracé pour un conflit
avec quelqu'un qui n'existe plus beau
jeu pour une raison de liberté
d'expression a prétendu loisirs et on
n'est pas vraiment comme je le disais
dans un pays communiste où que ce soit
choisir on a quand même droit de
s'exprimer au delà des communistes en
france fait attention
josé cayzac attention attention la
manière de les connaître et savoir qu'il
ya beaucoup plus de journalistes qui
avaient créé les articles là dessus
jusqu'à j'étais pas au courant mais j'ai
appris que maintenant récemment de dire
que le sélectionneur fait n'importe quoi
en france et la croatie la france si
spécial c'est sûr que je n'aimais pas le
championnat l'équipe
mais le problème c'est que si tu es je
disais au cinéma dit à gauche c'est une
profession n'a pas de salaire on bosse
comme des dingues pour devenir champion
pour certains à prendre 30 ans pour
l'autre 20 ans pour certains et 50 ans
presque
et puis la seule chose la seule chose
qu'on demande le mouvement représenté
notre pays qu'on est nous il faut encore
remplir plein de critères n'ai pas
baissé les lots sur telle ou telle mois
exactement sur un seul mois
ou sur je ne sais pas quoi donc torres
et c'est pour ça qu'on vous aime les
champions parce que vous faites quelque
chose qu'on ne pourrait pas faire nous
aller au-devant exécutés par les stages
ouverts si dead ou avoir ramé s'est
exprimée métier comprendre c'est
compliqué mais c'est normal
nous fatigue en ne cédant rien je trouve
vraiment que c'est pour un plus mais ça
leur mannino parce que tu es une grande
championne il faut diagonale tv là aussi
pour leurs précieux pour que le public
aussi découvre découvre les champions
les parties mais aussi peu leur vie
savoir comment c'est la piste le
champion
et puis bon mais un petit peu les
histoires qu'il peut y avoir autour pour
comprendre mieux un peu mieux le monde
du jeu d'échecs je te remercie beaucoup
je souhaiterais forcément une deuxième
moitié de tournois aussi bonne j'avais
essayé triplé mon titre et la première
pourquoi pas est pas facile parce que
justement ça va jouer beaucoup sur dow
matches qui viennent après le jour de
réponse et voilà aider parce qu'on va
suivre avec grand intérêt forcément et
on te souhaite le meilleur
et voilà bon on a pas de favori sur
talonnade tv on est nouveau tout les
champions bien subir mais on te remercie
beaucoup on t'aime beaucoup se demandent
à tva on te remercie évident c'est que
tu es venu déjà plusieurs fois puisqu'on
a fait aussi on a fait des leçons et
pour les débutants le point voilà des
leçons pour apprendre que les ouvertures
les finales un peu tout ça et voilà
merci commencer je le souhaitais les
bonnes parties à tout le monde
j'espère qu'on va démontrer notre
maximum en fait c'est sa principale
n'est pas gâchée par ses vêtements
merci beaucoup dit no merci beaucoup de
nous avoir suivis vers cette émission
cinquantaine de cas spécial avec nino
maso a dit qu'on reverra peut-être même
sens c'est probable parce qu'elle est
elle est en tête pour l'instant du
tournoi mais évidemment il reste encore
presque une moitié de tourner un petit
peu moins d'une moitié de tourner à
faire donc c'est quand même on est
encore loin du titre mais c'est possible
aussi que tu reviennes mais sur pourquoi
pas un troisième titre
merci à bientôt sur des gones ltv merci
merci au revoir